around the world people from different
cultures have beloved sweets we
salvadorians have many but one of my
favorites is torrejas for me dore has
our call back to memories of my abuelita
tere who would bring our family together
under one roof to celebrate special
occasions amongst the parade of kisses
and hugs i remember sitting back in awe
of my tias and abuelita at how they
would prepare the festivities with so
much care and love i can feel the
tenderness and the love of these
memories in a bite of a toreja toda has
our warm spongy slices of bread soaked
in a cinnamony syrup so that every bite
is an explosion of flavor sweetness and
deliciousness that just melts in your
mouth no one made better thought of
house than maya bolita and unfortunately
when she passed away things changed like
what happens with a lot of families
dealing with loss some families come
together and some families shift apart
mine was the latter my dream is to one
day own a home and bring the family back
together through our food and
celebration but there's one big problem
i don't know the recipe but thankfully
my mom does so i had her send it over to
me so i could just give it a try and get
one step closer to my dreams
and a delicious laura and if i have any
trouble i'll just call her hopefully she
answers because this should be fairly
interesting
[Music]
all righty y'all the first step is we're
going to take 12 eggs we're going to
separate the egg yolk from the egg
whites that's always really hard i
always get really lazy and i just like
throw it in it's fine i'll eat the whole
egg but
let's see let's try let's see what
happens so this is what all my fancy
cooking friends do they like
swish the little baby oak the little
baby yolk like this this was working
beautifully
i'm putting the yolks in this bowl and
the and the shells in this bowl and i
just got a little bit of yolk in my bowl
but it's fine it's just a little bit of
extra look that's what i've been told i
just have to do this uh
ten more times
all right so we've got plenty of egg
here to spare i'm like a optimist and i
stay optimistic until the very end so
even though there's some yolk in here i
have a feeling that it's gonna be
delicious so i am ready for the next
step which is to whisk it ah
look at this little beautiful whisk
[Music]
the next thing i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
whisk these egg whites for about five to
seven minutes until it gets a little
fluffy speed it up
i feel like my mom has always told me to
come and watch her make this and i never
actually
went in to watch her so it's getting a
little soapy i'm not sure if that's what
it's supposed to look like but i'm
hoping that it is
so i've been whisking for a while and
i'm actually not sure if this is how
it's supposed to look so i'm going to
call my mom before i add in the egg
yolks just to make sure that we're on
the right path hi nina i'm making my
three house does this look right to you
oh okay keep going
[Music]
higher
how do i know when it's ready
but do you think this looks ready to
start mixing in mom yeah
yeah so i will call you back mom thank
you very much okay
love you bye all right so now i'm gonna
start adding a little bit of the egg
yolk a little bit by little bit
as my mom says
it's changing the texture it's making a
little a little thicker i feel like with
a lot of latin cultures our snacks are
different our food is different so like
we never had lunchables we didn't really
have chips we always had like tortillas
which means
feels that you make by hand this looks
good to me i am ready to move on
[Music]
alrighty i've got my canola oil in the
pan i have my beautiful loaf of bread
here that i'm going to dip into my egg
concoction here and this is just like
what my mom calls like
which kind of just means like egg bread
basically you also want to use bread
that's like a little bit more
stale like day old you can also put it
in your oven for a little bit to not
necessarily toast it but just dry it out
just a little bit
alrighty so i have my bread it's looking
good i'm gonna dip it in my egg and then
i'm gonna put it in my pan to let it fry
for a little bit
dip it in the oil dip it in the pan
beautiful beautiful
kind of foamy
[Music]
i'm going to wait for it to get a little
golden brown and then i'm going to flip
it over it's kind of weird because i
don't really know what to expect when
you ask your mom or a lot of times in
your family about different recipes they
don't tell you time they don't tell you
what it's supposed to look like like i
don't know my mom usually just like
pushes me out of the kitchen she's like
oh give it i got it all right so this is
looking pretty good
i'm just gonna spread it a little bit
turn it around it's now like a really
pretty little gold toast baby right here
the syrup soaks in and it's just like
this spongy piece of toast it's gonna be
delicious
all right so now we're gonna work on the
syrup four cups
so here's my first
two
all right i'm adding in my second two
now
you put two little cinnamon sticks in
all right so i just added in my vanilla
which is kind of like hardened brown
sugar and it's just to kind of make it a
little sweet alrighty are we going to
let this come to a boil then i'm going
to lower the fire and let it come to a
simmer you're going to cook this for 15
minutes and it's going to get nice thick
and syrupy well according to my mom so
we'll see
[Music]
alrighty y'all so now we have the bread
in this casserole dish
the syrup is smelling so good and so
sweet and now i just get to pour it over
and that's my favorite part
[Music]
i'm super excited i'm going to let it
sit for 20 to 30 minutes
all right guys i'm going to plate the
throat i have now i'm going to put a
little bit of fruit on the side to make
it look pretty traditionally i haven't
really seen that but i'm excited to just
give it my own flair yes
oh my god i'm so i'm genuinely so
excited
i'm gonna put some bluebell please on
the side
you can't go wrong with some raspberries
either it looks good to me i just need
to call my mom and get her final
approval
all right finally finished you wanna see
it looks okay
does it look good
oh my god it's hard
it sounds like it's a simple thing to do
but it's hard to do it let's see
hmm that's really good congratulations
thank you
you did something
well i mean you heard it guys i feel
like i made my mom proud and i know that
i made my ulita proud too i'm sure that
she's watching me i'm sure that she
wants a bite so
shout out to you girls for you
that's bomb
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you